hi sal khan here from khan academy and
i'm just here to remind everyone that
khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization with the mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and we can only do
that work through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself and
if you need any extra motivation i will
remind you that there's actually a good
body of scientific research that one of
the top ways to become a happier person
which we all want to do
is to give to others and when you give
to khan academy the social return on
investment is really one of the highest
impact philanthropy things that you can
do so when you give those dollars not
only will it help tens of millions of
folks around the world but will also
make you a happier person as we go to
the back after 2020 and into 2021. to
make it even better every dollar you
give will be matched dollar for dollar
by a matching gift that we have received
from a very generous philanthropist
so as we make our way to the end of 2020
which has been a tough year and more
folks are dependent on khan academy and
being able to keep learning than ever
before i hope you seriously consider
thinking about how powerful a donation
to khan academy can be and how happy
that's going to make you